what's up guys it's Shawn Mendes and I'm
gonna be reading some of these they're
sweeties Shawn Mendes jawline can
literally cut me and I'd say thank you
you are weird and obsessed with pain but
I love you for it I would let Shawn
Mendes father every single egg in my
non-existent uterus lod oh my god this
is insane do you think if I asked nicely
that Shawn Mendes would choke me you
know the bad thing about this feed is is
that I've seen this so many times
don't ask anybody to choke you my body
is a temple and I watched Shawn Mendes
to bust down the walls poetic you should
write a song like about that how can
somebody not like Shawn Mendes he's
sweet talented and have you seen his
back muscles oh my god well thank you
yes sweet I have a whole Pinterest board
dedicated to Shawn Mendes ABS because
fine art must be recognized I don't do
my husband's are I watched Shawn Mendes
to light me on fire roast marshmallows
over my body haunted you guys are
haunted don't put these things on the
Internet
I literally want Shawn Mendes to smash
my skull between his massive good night
I think I could probably get arrested
for tweeting this stuff Shawn Mendes is
one thick bit let me see that Mendes see
you guys dug for the worst ones Vince -
I would like Shawn Mendes teeth not
reading that I'm sorry there's a line
then she crossed it Shawn Mendes I would
run a marathon barefoot on Lego as well
no I'm not reading that either guys that
was me reading first tweets yeah a
couple of you I'm sorry I didn't read
your tweets but you need to stop
tweeting things like that
[Music]